how could you forget what she did to us
how could you forget that I was supposed
to be your grade you will go you will
find the fairy godmother and you will
bring me back her magic wand
he's peasy could Maleficent and Audrey
team up in descendants for you and
Maleficent have a lot in common Audrey
it's almost as if you're the daughter
she's always wanted how ironic is that
it's really too bad that Maleficent is
still stuck in her lizard form if you
could find a way to change her back you
could work together to boot Mel off the
throne it's a win-win really we just
hope you fight your evil days behind you
or out smell will rue the day that she
ever stepped foot in auradon Maleficent
and Audrey have a common enemy but will
that be enough for them to team up in
descendants for if T for ever happens
we'd love to see Audrey and Maleficent
join forces and attempt to take over
auradon keep watching to find out which
major clue from descendants three hinted
towards Audrey and Maleficent working
together with the way things ended in
descendants three you would never
suspect that Audrey still had a bone to
pick with Ben and mal but we're not
buying Audrey's good girl act and wanted
to hurt you both I wanted to hurt all of
you but let's be real she wanted to hurt
them long before that Audrey was shocked
when Ben proposed - mal so much so that
she went to steal the Queen's crown from
the museum then and mal finally
apologized to Audrey when Hades saved
her but their apology was long overdue
Audrey might feel bad about what she did
but she still wants to be the Queen and
mal is still living the life that Audrey
always wanted so her good girl Act is
bound to fade sooner than later
Audrey literally screamed when Ben
proposed to Mouse so imagine what she'll
do when the lovers exchange I Do's
Audrey will probably receive an invite
to the wedding which is almost as bad as
not being invited at all she'll be
forced to watch the man of her dreams
marry someone else but you know who
won't be invited to the wedding well
listen Mouse very own mother we know for
a fact that Maleficent doesn't like
being left off the guest list so we
wouldn't be surprised if the little evil
lizard slithered her way into Audrey's
thoughts what better way to stop a
wedding than to let Maleficent crash it
but finding Maleficent and turning her
back into an evil fairy won't be easy
luckily for Audrey she and Maleficent
are fated to team up and even out the
score Maleficent terrorized Audrey's
family so she would be the last person
Audrey went to for help right well not
exactly the descendants franchise has a
knack for irony so Audrey and Maleficent
could very well end up working together
after all
Evie ended up falling in love with Doug
who's the son of one of her mom's sworn
enemies it takes a very special person
to work with Maleficent and Maleficent
is known for going solo she's got some
major trust issues and only really trust
her pet raven diablo and receptor
dragon's eye but for some strange reason
her scepter called out to audrey when
she crossed paths with it but most
surprisingly the scepter let Audrey use
it without condemning her to 1,000 years
of sleep so clearly Audrey and
Maleficent share a special bond after
all now walked by that very same scepter
in that very same museum and it never
called out to her
what makes Audrey and Maleficent even
better allies is that they both have
common goals
first and foremost Maleficent wants to
get revenge on mal who totally betrayed
her in the first Descendants movie
obviously mal made the right choice but
she did keep her mom as a pet lizard
instead of returning her to the aisle
both Maleficent and Audrey want to show
mal who's boss and they most definitely
aren't okay with her ruling over auradon
and the Isle of the Lost after what she
did to them we just hope that Maleficent
doesn't want to be queen because that
would put Audrey and Maleficent at odds
the first thing Audrey would need to do
is get her hands on Maleficent scepter
again then she could use it to locate
Maleficent and undo the spell that
turned her into the lizard in the first
place then Audrey could fill Maleficent
in on the last year's events and they
could plan to ruin mal and Ben's wedding
since Audrey still wants to be liked by
the people of auradon it's in her best
interest to act innocent once Mouse out
of the picture Audrey could put a love
spell on Ben and caught her way onto the
throne
Maleficent always feared that mal wasn't
evil enough she pushed mal to commit
terrible crimes and saw her daughter's
good nature get in the way time and time
again that's a problem she'll never have
with Audrey Audrey has been a mean girl
since day one she takes what she thinks
she deserves and lashes out when things
don't go as planned
Audrey is the daughter Maleficent always
wanted and together they could come
close to taking over auradon we can
already imagine the look on everyone's
face when Maleficent crashes her
daughter's wedding just like she did at
Aurora's christening the fact that
Maleficent scepter chose Audrey has to
mean something
Audrey will stop at nothing to be the
queen of auradon
but if usurping mal is on her agenda
Maleficent and Audrey better succeed no
ifs ands or buts because if they failed
mal won't hesitate to turn both of them
into lizards and let her future children
keep them as pets do you think Audrey is
done with being the queen of mean or
will she strike again on
now's wedding day sound off in the
comments thanks for watching we hope you
enjoyed our video don't forget to
subscribe to the things we'll catch you
next time
[Music]